The guy typically credited with inventing
what we know as the modern novel was Miguel
de Cervantes with his cumbersome 800+ page
book, Don Quixote.
But what if I told you that the real antecedent
for the modern novel was created by … ladies.
Before the rise of what would become the modern
novel, there was Amatory fiction.
Amatory fiction was a genre of fiction that
became popular in Britain in the late 17th
century and early 18th century.
As its name implies, amatory fiction is preoccupied
with sexual love and romance.
Most of its works were short stories, it was
dominated by women, and women were the ones
responsible for sharing and promoting their
own work.
There are quite a few ladies we could discuss,
but today we are going to focus on the Big
Three, the literary lady squad that was dubbed
"the fair triumvirate of wit" made up of:
Eliza Haywood, Delarivier Manley, Aphra Behn.
Clara Reeve, an English gothic novelist, wrote
about the history of prose fiction in The
Progress of Romance (1785) and mentions with
some shade “the French and Spanish Romance,
and the writings of Mrs. Behn, Mrs Manly,
and Mrs. Heywood.”
So even as early as the 18th century as people
were documenting who was crafting the trajectory
of the written word, women were very much
being noted.
What makes amatory fiction so interesting,
and probably why it has been forgotten to
time, was that these were stories about women,
by women that explored their sexuality, their
pleasures, and the limits of autonomy they
were allowed to have in their lives.
Before the Puritanical era of the Victorian
prudes and just general haters came along.
In the Typical ruined woman lady plot: young
innocent woman ends up meeting a handsome,
probably dark haired man who never smiles
and only ever grins or smirk.
She is seduced and later on deceived by dark
haired man and ends up ruinedddd for having
sex outside of wedlock--reinforcing the notion
that women’s value is based around their
virginity and purity and it can be taken from
them.
Then she had to throw herself off the cliff
because now she has nothing to offer the world.
Well, Amatory fiction asked: “but what if
she just liked sex and didn’t die?”
… some of the time...
Amatory fiction was considered immoral by
contemporary standards, because it allowed
women to have *scandalous* love affairs without
being "punished" because women are not allowed
to feel pleasure without consequences.
The contemporary dismissal is part of the
reason why these stories and the authors involved
in them were not given their due credit for
the rise of the novel.
So much so that later 18th century female
writers like Frances Burney really wanted
to separate themselves from the raunchy concept
of female authorship.
They weren’t like other female writers,
they were cool writers who wrote hyper realistic
stories about women on the cusp of being rich
if they could just marry wealthy.
Relatable every day content.
In "Novel," "Romance," and Popular Fiction
in the First Half of the Eighteenth Century
by Dieter Schulz, Schulz argues that the works
of the three big people you might have heard
of!!
Daniel Defoe (Robinson Crusoe), Samuel Richardson
(Clarissa), and Henry Fielding (Tom Jones),
should “be viewed as a reaction against
the kind of romanticized novel or novella
produced by such writers as Aphra Behn, [Delarivier]
Manley, and Eliza Haywood, rather than as
an alternative to the tradition of "high"
romance presented by the heroic romances of
the seventeenth century.”
Haters.
Daniel Defoe with his 1722 novel Moll Flanders
made sure to set up his stories as “private
histories” that were telling a more realistic
weighty story and were not “idle.”
Aka, not about fun hot girl summer things.
Even back then male critics were very glad
to dismiss the concept of a happily ever after
as “fluff.”
All three members of the wit squad were widely
read and Haywood’s Love in Excess was, after
Gulliver’s Travels and Robinson Crusoe,
one of the most popular works of fiction of
the era.
Yet we still read those other two works (mostly
abridged, but still).
So, it’s 1792 and Mary Wollstonecraft has
published A Vindication of the Rights of Woman
and dudes are salty.
Male critics already think that women who
have succeeded in literature are because men
have given them permission.
As Jane Spencer explains, “The public reception
of [Wollstonecraft's] The Rights of Woman
plainly demonstrates that women writers had
been accepted only on condition that they
remained within a limited, feminine sphere,
and did not disturb men's dominance of the
'real' world outside it.
'Women we have often placed near the throne
of literature', wrote the Critical reviewer
of Wollstonecraft's work: but 'if they seize
it, forgetful of our fondness, we can hurl
them from it'.”
And the way most women worked this power play
was by working satire and political commentary
into their works.
What were some of these saucy stories about?
Well let’s see.
One of Aphra Behn’s most scandalous novels
was History of the Nun or The Fair Vow Breaker:
This Behn novel is about a young woman named
Isabella who is the daughter of a count, who
is sent to a nunnery when her mother dies.
She ends up falling in love with this guy
named Henault, breaks her vows as nun, and
commits some petty theft which gets her husband
disowned.
He eventually joins the army and ends up presumed
dead.
She ends up marrying a rich dude named Villenoys,
who was in love with her from way back when.
However, Henault ends up coming back and Isabella
smothers him to death and disposes of the
body because she is afraid of being shamed
for commiting bigamy.
Girl, murder is worse.
Isabella has such a good reputation, she almost
gets away with it, but ends up confessing
and is executed.
Before she is put to death, she gives an impassioned
speech that makes everyone go: “you know,
she’s pretty a cool lady, sucks she has
to die.”
Fantomina, or Love in a Maze by Eliza Haywood
is about this nameless high brow woman who
ends up having a dalliance with a man after
a night at the theater.
The man, called Beauplaisir, ends
up getting bored and doing the 1725 version
of ghosting.
In response, the protagonist dons three different
disguises to keep seducing Beauplaisir until
they both end up getting bored with each other.
The story ends with our protagonist eventually
getting pregnant and being forced by her mother
to confess all this to Beauplaisir.
Beauplaisir offers marriage and her response
is: No.
Our heroine gets sent off to a French nunnery.
Meanwhile Beauplaisir has to deal with the
fact that he is very, very, very gullible.
Kathleen Lubey in “Eliza Haywood’s Amatory
Aesthetic” writes.
Haywood chooses amatory content not only as
a call to a sexually attuned audience, but
as a mode of immersing her readers [...] in
states of extreme aesthetic engagement that
acquaint them with human experience with an
intensity no other material can.
Far from being a degraded form of sensationalist
writing, amatory fiction contains the most
instructive potential for eliciting readers'
affect and calling their attention to the
implications of that affect.
These stories all have different endings,
but all of them show women struggling in a
system that very much wants to be passive
actors in their own story.
They seek love, romance, sex, and adventure.
Each of these texts are on the heroine’s
side and even if they were forced to have
non-radical endings at times, the fact that
it gives voice to these desires is radical.
English scholar Toni O'Shaughnessy Bowers
explained:
“Behn, Manley, Haywood, and their peers
were writing for women increasingly cut off
from the world outside the domestic circle.
That world was, they knew, full of traps laid
especially for them; even the smallest error
could result in permanent social alienation.
Under these circumstances, amatory fiction
provided Augustan women with a sense of involvement
in the outside world--which, for all its dangers
and disappointments, had great advantages
over restrictive domesticity--while allowing
them to maintain a safe distance from it.”
Even marriage, in these books, is treated
as something a woman has to want, rather than
a reward for good behavior as it is in Samuel
Richardson’s Pamela or The History of Sir
Charles Grandison.
In 1753, Mary Wortley Montagu remarked, “Richardson
is so eager for the multiplication of [marriages]
I suppose he is some parish curate, whose
chief profit depends on weddings and christenings.”
For those who are not aware that is a soft
drag (it is not a read).
But these women weren’t just writing lust
tales for the sake of it.
Interwoven was heavy political satire.
In The New Atalantis, an influential political
satire by Delarivier Manley, which have the
goddesses Justice and Virtue on earth witnesses
all kinds of human nastiness: orgies, seductions,
and assault.
Just terrible.
It mocked several members of the Whigg party
including Sarah Churchill, who was then a
favorite of the Queen.
In fact the scandal and public fever around
Manley’s writing was particularly impactful
in damaging the relationship between Sarah
Churchill and Queen Anne, although they decided
not to include that in The Favourite for some
reason.
Manley ended up being arrested, but she was
adamant that the figures in the book were
totally fictional and eventually charges were
dropped so it couldn’t be libel so there.
Professor of English, Catherine Gallagher,
explains of Manley’s work:
“The “allegorical style” favored by
Manley, for example, involved telling scandalous
stories about recognizable real persons, with
the name and some circumstances altered.
The stories were given distant historical,
exotic, or mythical settings and were often
interspersed with stories lacking apparent
referents…
What Manley gained from the allegorical necessity
of altering and therefore inventing circumstances
was a representational density that enabled
especially effective libel.
Manley’s talent was for crafting the invented
circumstances into what we would now call
a “novelistically” satisfying story, one
read for its own sake as well as for its scandalous
referentiality.”
If these women were so impactful and interesting,
to the point where they ruined semi-gay royal
relationships, why aren’t they more well
known?
Well, it was because they were raunchy.
Other female authors of the time didn’t
want to be associated with the fair triumvirate
who were also called “prostitutes of the
pen.”
William Warner, an English essayist wrote:
“The incorporation of the novel of amorous
intrigue within the elevated novel of the
1740s--in, for example, Pamela, Joseph Andrews,
Clarissa, and Tom Jones--is one of the means
by which old pleasures are disowned and forgotten.
In their novels of the 1740s, Richardson and
Fielding promote this “forgetting,” first
by defacing the novel of amorous intrigue,
and then by providing their own novels as
replacements for novels they characterize
as degraded and immoral.
These new novels overwrite--by disavowing
but appropriating, tossing out but recycling--the
novels they spurn…”
It wasn’t until early feminists and other
female authors like Virginia Woolf rediscovered
them that history started giving these ladies
their due.
The works of these women are being studied
more, but due to the racey subject matter
most people ever hear of these women in college
or graduate school.
Despite the work they did to help develop
what we now know of the English novel, they
are still under loved and under appreciated,
much like Amy Adams at the Oscars.
When we talk about female authorship we can
always pull out the big guns: Brontes, Austen,
Alcott, Woolf, and James, but that is such
a small cafeteria table, when the reality
is that there was a whole school of female
writers who not only wrote, but did it well
enough to set the standard.
To quote Virginia Woolf: "All women together
ought to let flowers fall upon the tomb of
Aphra Behn which is, most scandalously but
rather appropriately, in Westminster Abbey,
for it was she who earned them the right to
speak their minds.”